ein surfer überlebt ein hai angriffen
nur weil er dem tier mit ja mit seinem
surfbord auf kopf und mein schlägt erst
dann lässt das tier von ihm ab aber er
übersteht den kampf nicht unverletzt er
muss trotzdem ins krankenhaus mit einer
klaffenden wunde
es ist ein freudiges wiedersehen für
alle fünf unbekannte heute freunde fürs
leben
für mich sind sie einfach nur helden es
war ein ganz normaler tag die männer
surfen in bank dabei an der westküste
australiens
doch plötzlich wird der surf trip für
phil rudd zu einem kampf um leben und
tod
der 28 jährige wird von einem weißen hai
angegriffen
laut eigenen aussagen saß will auf
seinem board er erinnert sich nur an die
wucht mit der der hai auf sein surfbrett
traf im nächsten moment war sein brett
in zwei hälften gebissen
instinktiv drückte er das was von seinem
brett übrig war richtung hey um sich zu
schützen andere surfer kriegen dies mit
ich weiß nur noch dass jemand laut
schrie und als ich mich umdrehte sah sie
schwimmen direkt zu ihm um zu helfen und
werden zeugen wie viel dem heim mehrmals
mit bloßen händen auf die nase haut und
ihn damit in die flucht schlägt
du musst einfach helfen du kannst gar
nicht anders
warum auch immer ich weiß es nicht es
ist ein instinkt du kannst dich nicht
umdrehen du musst hin egal wie
gefährlich es ist an land angekommen
geht es anschließend würfel direkt mit
dem krankenwagen ins krankenhaus
zum ersten mal seit der hai-attacke
trifft voll auf seine neuen freunde und
sie können gemeinsam lachen und jetzt
ist mir gerhard wegner von shark project
live zugeschaltet hallo herr wegner hat
in der surfer dort alles richtig gemacht
instinktiv gehandelt indem er das
surfbrett er auf das tier losgegangen
ist sozusagen ihnen das auf kopf und
maul gehauen hat das kann man natürlich
nichts sagen wenn man die situation
nicht richtig sieht oder richtig kennt
klagt ist wenn ein tier zu nahe kommt es
war scheinbar ein richtiger angriffe auf
das surfbrett als runde gefallen
und wurde danach verletzt die verletzung
die er hat sind kein biss das ist ja
doch und business ist ein test bis das
hier probiert was es ist
und wenn derjenige den armen und beinen
wegzieht entstehen sogenannte sich und
der verletzung das sind diese schnitte
die man sieht auf dem bild das ich
bekommen habe aber ja wenn das hier so
nahe ist
kann es schon helfen ob die schnauze
hauen
warum kommt es seien gerade so häufig
vor dieser hai angriffe dass immer
weniger haie gibt wir menschen töten pro
jahr etwa 150 millionen dann liegt es
nicht daran dass jetzt da ganz viele
haie zusammen sind sondern es sind
einfach mehr menschen im wasser
das kann sein dass einfach durch corona
viele nicht geschafft haben wir wochen
und monate hinweg und jetzt verstärkt
dorthin strömen die tiere haben aber in
der zeit ihr habitat ihr revier neu
entdeckt sind also da wenn die menschen
kommen dass eine mögliche erklärung die
andere ist dass haie und orientiert sind
das heißt sie folgten beute fischen und
wenn jetzt fischschwärme durchströmung
oder hitze in nähe des strandes
getrieben worden sind da auch
entsprechend mehr haie und wenn dann
entsprechend wir menschen kommen
gibt es ein höheres risiko dass etwas
passieren können die meisten haiangriffe
passieren ja in den usa oder wie in
diesem fall in australien warum ist das
so
das sind die längsten strände der welt
sowohl florida als auch australien
australien hat mit allen inseln 60.000
km küstenlinie
das heißt es ist ja nicht ein hotspot
das ist eine kleine welt und die es hier
geht
und das inhalt auch sehr viele server
und server windsurfer kitesurfer die
schaffen es einfach in gebiete zu kommen
die früher jagdgebiete der haie waren
jetzt durch menschen gestört werden
dadurch kommt es zu diesen treffen und
wie sollte man sich verhalten wenn man
auf einheit trifft erst mal ganz ruhig
weil die hi-hat den mensch nicht als
beute gehören nicht in gebäude raster
sondern wir sind etwas fremdes da die
tiere futter orientiert neugierige sind
kommen sie wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal
gucken was das eigentlich ist das dein
wasser schwimmt und wenn man sich dann
falsch verhält zum beispiel panik
herumwirbelt und versucht zum strand zu
kommen denn denke hey das könnte doch
heute sein und setzten test bis
anprobiert was das ist verletzung also
ruhig bleiben das tier beobachten
und
sag möglichst senkrecht im bett stehen
das kennen die tiere nicht von ihrer
beute das schreckt sie ab
aber ruhig bleiben liebt fährmann ein
auf der straße einen großen und zieht
den man nicht kennt
erst mal gucken was passiert und dann
vorsichtig bewegt